Steve McQueen may have had Top Billing
in 1968 s bullet but the Ford Mustang
Fastback he raced across the screen
stole the show the car chase scenes
featuring the Mustang are often credited
as some of the best in cinema history
adding to the car's mystique it was
thought to be lost for 40 years before
resurfacing in 2014 the Mustang is one
of five cars being celebrated this month
at the historic vehicle associations
cars at the capital exhibition in
Washington DC all are on the national
historic vehicle register and are
recognized as historically significant
by the Library of Congress the plymouth
voyager revolutionized the car industry
we're back in business and in a hell of
a big way chrysler CEO lee iaccoca
introduced this the first minivan in
1983 the vehicles saved Chrysler from
bankruptcy and became a symbol of
suburbia in the 80s and 90s changing the
way American families travel also
featured the last Model T Ford to be
manufactured in 1927 Henry Ford and son
Edsel personally drove this car
nicknamed the tin Lizzie off the
assembly line
and a Cadillac type 57 used in World War
1 that is celebrating its 100th birthday
the 1961 Ferrari 250 GT California
rounding out the exhibition another car
with some Hollywood history the red
sports car Ferris Bueller borrowed to
use on his day off
only this car is just a replica of a
1961 Ferrari 250 GT one of three used in
the classic comedy
that is pretty yeah today's the only day
that they're all together on the display
on the mall Wow Wow can I say that the
plymouth voyager just not nearly as sexy
as the mustang on the mall I'm sorry
plymouth voyager but and i got to say
this photograph behind me here of the
Mustang and the monument can you see it
there it is with the monument behind it
that is just the coolest thing I've ever
seen look at that I mean it reminds you
that cars are pieces of work they ship
and tie their pieces of art